on va poursuivre notre nos travaux de
commission ce matin avec
ce rapport important réalisé sur la
stratégie de financement de la filière
musicale en France on a eu l'occasion à
nombreuses reprises dans parler je suis
rod accueillir évidemment notre collègue
Julien barjetton et qui est accompagné
de François Hurard inspecteur général
des affaires culturelles de Guillaume
Lachaussée inspecteur des finances et de
haute charbonniers inspectrice des
finances venue nous présenter ce rapport
qui a donc été commandé par la première
ministre
qui est donc été commandée par la
première ministre en octobre dernier et
remis à la ministre de la Culture il y a
quelques jours le 20 avril
cher Julien inutile de rappeler à quel
point la publication de ce rapport était
attendu par les acteurs de la filière
musicale et même au-delà par l'ensemble
du monde de la création
c'est cette attente était sans doute
pour une part justifiée par la
difficulté de la mission qui vous était
imparti définir en quelques mois les
voiles et les moyens permettant de lever
les les incertitudes auxquelles se
trouvent confronté le Centre national de
la musique depuis la fin de la pandémie
en recherchant et je cite ici la lettre
de mission que vous adressez la première
ministre un consensus aussi large que
possible autour de vos propositions nous
avions pourtant pu constater ici même à
l'occasion d'une table ronde rassemblant
les principaux acteurs du secteur
autour de Jean-Philippe thiollet le
caractère difficilement conciliable pour
ne pas dire contradictoire
des attentes formulées par les
représentants des différentes
organisations à l'égard du CNM nous
avions aussi pu mesurer à quel point les
questions posées en 2020 par Jean
Raymond Hugonnet alors rapporteur du
projet de loi portant la création du CNM
et que l'on pourrait résumer par quel
financement quel participation
financière des différents acteurs quelle
mission pour cette maison commune de la
musique demeurait d'actualité deux ans
après sa création et deux ans après le
travail important fait par le CNM durant
la crise de la covine nous sommes bien
entendu très désireux de vous entendre
aujourd'hui pour nous présenter les
réponses que vous apportez à ces
différentes questions je précise
d'ailleurs qu'elle dépasse largement la
création d'une taxe streaming destinée
au financement du CNM la presse a
beaucoup retenu cet aspect là
mais dans le rapport que j'ai lu il y a
bien d'autres aspects qui concernent ce
secteur du de la musique et nous
attendons non sans impatience la
traduction législative de ces
propositions préciserait du reste quels
sont les propositions qui nécessitent
une traduction législative que la
ministre de la Culture s'est engagé à
présenter dès l'examen du projet de loi
de finance sans plus tarder
Julien je vais te céder la parole merci
monsieur le Président merci à vous je
vais essayer de faire une présentation
brève parce que je pense que le plus
important c'est que nous ayons un débat
c'est un exercice un peu particulier
puisqu'il s'agit d'une mission qui m'a
été confiée par le gouvernement la
première ministre donc pas dans le cadre
de la commission mais je remercie
vraiment le président d'avoir accepté
cet exercice pour qu'on puisse en
débattre donc je vais je pense que j'ai
à faire quand même à des spécialistes
des politiques culturelles notamment de
la musique donc vraiment le plus
important c'est que nous puissions nous
puissions échanger je voudrais aussi à
mon tour remercier l'équipe
qui m'a accompagné et on a réalisé un
travail assez colossal d'audition et
donc je voudrais vraiment remercier à
mon tour François au début Guillaume qui
sont là et d'ailleurs si vous en êtes
d'accord je pourrais les inviter aussi à
répondre à des questions je sais pas si
ça se fait mais aussi pourront s'il le
souhaite sur faire part de de leur
marque ma conviction lors de cette de
cette mission c'est que au-delà du sujet
du CNM qui polarisait je pense que il
est temps d'avoir une stratégie forte et
ambitieuse pour la musique en France
il y a des politiques bien installées
parce que
elles ont bénéficié notamment de centres
nationaux qui ont précédé à la création
du ministère de la Culture
le Centre national du cinéma et le
Centre national du livre la musique on
pourra revenir pour tout un tas de
raisons n'a jamais bénéficié d'un même
élan jusqu'à la création du CNM en 2020
et qui a été tout de suite pour la risée
par le covid il y a eu le plan Landowski
bien sûr qui a marqué les esprits parce
que c'était l'éducation notamment
musicale et puis le tissu des orchestres
des opéras etc mais la musique n'a pas
ensuite eu le même élan sauf au moment
de du ministère de Jack Lang sous
l'impulsion d'une politique marquée par
les smacks et notamment la prise en
compte donc de la musique dites
nouvelles dans le ministère de la
Culture
il n'y a pas le même effort budgétaire
la même histoire etc notre conviction
c'est que cette stratégie doit d'abord
insister sur l'exportation
nous vivons dans un monde où il y a
évidemment un débat sur le soft power
une compétition très forte sur
l'influence culturelle et donc
l'exploitation doit être le premier
pilier d'une stratégie pour la musique
en France que ce soit la musique
enregistrée ou le spectacle vivant qui
sont les deux grandes dimensions même si
cela progresse il y a des chiffres qui
sont en progression par rapport au monde
la France perd quand même des places et
nous sommes passés à la septième place
juste devant la Corée du Sud mais qui
mais non une stratégie très offensive
avec la K-pop peut nous nous dépasser
donc le premier aspect c'est de mettre
le paquet sur l'exportation aider
davantage de tourner et promouvoir les
artistes français certes il y a des
réussites on s'appuie ils sont cités
dans le rapport elles sont bien connues
que ce soit dans le classique ou dans
les musiques nouvelles mais pour autant
une stratégie d'influence de la musique
nécessite de mettre le paquet sur
l'exportation deuxième Pilet dans une
stratégie très forte pour la musique
c'est l'innovation la musique c'est le
secteur qui a été le plus impacté par
innovation et très vite notamment avec
le piratage ce qui a créé la crise du
disque donc la musique c'est un secteur
qui a toujours bougé en fonction des
innovations technologiques le 78 tours
ça a changé la façon d'enregistrer les
œuvres on dit d'ailleurs que parfois que
certains chefs accéléraient les morceaux
pour que ça tienne sur les disques quand
il y avait trois grands vinyles pour
avoir les opéras et c'est pour ça qu'on
jouait parfois très vite les ouvertures
notamment
et c'est une anecdote réelle donc il y a
un impact et le jazz on sait très bien
que les standards de jazz ont évolué et
les 7 ont changé à partir du moment où
ils étaient ils ont été enregistrés bon
donc c'est un c'est un secteur toujours
très impacté par is innovation mais là
aujourd'hui de nous de façon massive
bien sûr le stream on y reviendra mais
au-delà nous les évoquons dans le
rapport la blockchain les NFT le les
metaves les différents sujets
d'innovation sont en train de percuter
la musique et évidemment l'intelligence
artificielle avec la création
automatique de morceaux notamment pour
de la musique accompagnante des dessins
animés ou des films etc donc il y a un
enjeu technologique majeur ce serait le
deuxième grand pilier d'une d'une
stratégie en faveur de la musique la
troisième la troisième dimension c'est
bien sûr le la place des indépendants
dans une stratégie
industrielle classique il faut maintenir
un écosystème un écosystème où il y a
des grands c'est pas choquant qui est
des grands des majors mais il faut aussi
que il y ait des et des PME et puis des
artisans donc l'idée c'est vraiment de
pouvoir préserver ce label il est menacé
quand même par des phénomènes de
concentration par des phénomènes de 360
degrés de plateformes que nous décrivons
et donc
nous pensons que maintenir les centres
de décision en France maintenir de la
création de richesse en France est un
enjeu majeur également pour la musique
afin de défendre cette chaîne qui va des
indépendants jusqu'aux producteurs parce
qu'on voit bien que il n'assure plus le
même rôle il y a des découvertes qui
sont assurés par plutôt des labels
indépendants et puis ensuite qui sont
repris par des moyens et et des gros et
nous avons des indépendants en France
qui font notre fierté mais il faut aussi
les les préserver quatrième grande
dimension de cette politique c'est bien
sûr le
le fait que la création de richesse
doivent irriguer les territoires il faut
renforcer la dimension territoriale de
la musique au-delà de ce qui existe
notamment en matière de formation et
d'emploi il y a des enjeux de
transformation des métiers qui sont
massifs il y a des choses qui sont
faites on pourrait revenir si vous
souhaitez sur les contrats de filières
les conventions que signes le Centre
national de la musique mais il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin pour que dans
toutes les régions dans toutes les
métropoles dans tous les territoires
ruraux on puisse bénéficier de transfert
de savoir-faire de partage de
compétences de pôles d'employeurs etc il
y a de très nombreuses expérimentations
qui sont menées mais il faut qu'elles
irriguent davantage et que il y ait une
circulation des bonnes pratiques toute
cette stratégie elle s'appuie sur une
nécessité impérieuse qui est
l'observation cette filière
manque d'une observation fiable partagée
objective et sur laquelle tout le monde
serait d'accord
les chiffres sont souvent produits par
le snap donc voilà c'est un syndicat
professionnel et au-delà il n'y a le le
pôle d'observation qui était prévu par
le déjà le CNV repris par le CNM n'a
jamais vraiment pu pleinement s'exercer
mais il y a des choses il y a des études
mais en tout cas pas de façon suffisante
pour que nous puissions
bénéficier d'une observation d'une
réalité d'études qui permettent
finalement d'étayer un accord et donc de
pouvoir construire une des politiques
publiques ça c'est vraiment une
spécificité de la filière sur sur ses
besoins parce que nous avons besoin donc
de
davantage de chiffres partagés je
voudrais quand même vous en livrer
quelques-uns que nous avons trouvé je
remercie la mission
parce qu'on parle souvent par exemple de
la musique française etc
c'est 45% des écoutes la musique
française francophone
sur le les plateformes de streaming mais
c'est seulement 14% des références et
les chansons en anglais c'est 43% donc
en réalité on n'est pas si loin
mais c'est 56% des références
sur
si on maintient si on garde le top 1%
on est en réalité à 25% d'écoute qui
concerne le bas de catalogue le bac
catalogue c'est-à-dire des références de
plus de 10 ans on nous dit toujours
c'est les nouveautés qui sont écoutés et
si on retire les 1% des plus écoutés qui
sont
évidemment souvent des nouveautés on est
à peu près à 30%
. voilà la réalité c'est quand même que
si vous regardez les chiffres le
catalogue Bruce printing ou celui de
baume Dylan ce sont vendus 500 millions
d'euros chacun et en regardant les
introductions en Bourse on se rend
compte qu'il y a de la valeur qui a créé
et qui se déplacée pourquoi cette
stratégie est possible selon nous
pourquoi est-ce que elle en a besoin
parce que l'état de la musique
aujourd'hui à la fois le permet et je
dirais le justifier pour y revenir ainsi
dans nos échanges il y a un rattrapage
de la crise du disque au niveau mondial
nous ne sommes plus dans la situation de
2010 nous ne sommes même plus dans
celles tout à fait de 2017 aujourd'hui
en 2022 le chiffre d'affaires mondial de
la musique a rattrapé celui des débuts
des années 2000 alors certes il s'est
considérablement déplacé puisque 61% du
revenu c'est le stream
et le téléchargement c'est
considérablement réduit et les ventes de
disques physiques se sont effondrées
mais sur la musique enregistrée au
niveau mondial il y a aujourd'hui un
rattrapage ça n'est pas tout à fait vrai
en France le chiffre d'affaires de la
musique enregistrée en France n'a pas
rattrapé le chiffre d'affaires de
moments où le disque était où on vendait
beaucoup de beaucoup de CD même si le
stream est multiplié par deux en quatre
ans les revenus liés au stream mais il y
a un retard nous sommes par exemple nous
avons moins d'abonnés en aux plateformes
de streaming payant en France que dans
d'autres pays on est à peu près à
18% et donc on a un chiffre d'affaires
de la musique en France qui est
enregistrée qui est toujours en dessous
de 1 milliard 920 millions mais
le stream progresse de 14 à 15% par an
par an donc c'est extrêmement fort
le spectacle vivant a repris après le
covid de façon contrastée ça dépend des
esthétiques c'est plus vrai pour la pop
que pour d'autres esthétiques la pop et
le rap on va dire musique urbaine et
moins pour d'autres et puis ça dépend
des jauges les très grandes jauges ont
bien repris les jauges moyennes c'est
moyen les petites jauges souffrent en
gros on pourra y revenir mais on a une
reprise contrastée de
de de de du spectacle vivre
la répartition de la valeur
là on a un manque aussi de chiffres et
de transparence on en parlait tout à
l'heure sur le numérique de manière
générale
on sait quand même que
le cadre juridique n'a pas changé c'est
toujours le même cadre les droits
d'auteur les droits voisins les
rémunérations sur le spectacle vivant
bon mais il y a eu des transformations
dans le secteur qui sont liés notamment
à des phénomènes comme l'autoproduction
donc de plus en plus de d'artistes
s'autoproduisent qui sont liées au fait
qu'il y a de plus en plus d'activités un
éclatement des activités dans la filière
musicale et en même temps certains
acteurs qui font du 360 degrés c'est à
dire qu'ils font à la fois de l'édition
de la production et de l'exploitation
etc donc on a une complexité de la
filière un des règles juridiques qui
n'ont pas changé depuis 85 on va dire
sur sur la rémunération en terme des
auteurs mais
un déplacement de la valeur qui se fait
en faveur quand même des majeurs puisque
le stream qui augmente beaucoup reverse
à peu près 70% de ce qu'il touche on dit
aux ayants droits mais en réalité aux
ayant droit c'est
à la production et donc ensuite ça
dépend des contrats qui lient les
maisons de production aux artistes et là
évidemment à ça dépend de la
contractualisation du type de contrat de
licence type de contrats etc et ce qui
fait que c'est là où je où on a besoin
d'observation extrêmement étayée donc
l'état de la musique à la fois dans sa
reprise
permet de pouvoir asseoir une création
de richesse et en même temps il reste
des défaillances on voit bien un niveau
français qui n'a pas repris niveau
mondial et il reste des imperfections de
marché qui justifient une intervention
ces imperfections de marché vous les
connaissez je ne vais pas les développer
vous les connaissez aussi bien que moi
c'est la défense des esthétiques plus
fragiles c'est le renouvellement et
l'émergence c'est-à-dire de faire monter
des nouveaux groupes et que chacun joue
son rôle c'est l'accès dans les
territoires à ce qu'il y ait une grande
une diffusion large de de la culture
à partir de ça cela justifie le rôle du
Centre national de la musique
le Centre national de la musique créé en
2020 a joué son rôle pleinement son rôle
à double titre d'abord dans la crise
tous les acteurs ont reconnu que il a
joué un rôle massif de soutien et rapide
efficace qui a permis de sauver la
filière ça je crois qu'il faut le redire
il commence à jouer un rôle qui est
souligné de rassemblement d'une filière
très éclatée cette filière là aussi on
pourrait revenir je ne développe pas
mais n'est pas
regroupé autour d'intérêts collectifs
comme d'autres il y a une diversité de
type d'entreprise une diversité de
fonction une diversité d'activités une
histoire différente qui font que elle ne
sait pas construite pleinement autour
d'objectifs partagés face à la puissance
publique je dis ça sans jugement moral
je ne porte aucun jugement moral je fais
un constat et d'ailleurs le nombre
d'auditions que nous avons dû mener 250
personnes rencontrées le montre à chaque
fois qu'on quelqu'un quelqu'un d'autre
voulait qu'on les voit parce que ils
disaient non non moi je suis plus
représentatif etc donc l'éclatement de
la filière le CNM commence à répondre à
ça comment à construire cette maison
commune parce que et bien elle rassemble
les différents acteurs musique
enregistrés spectacle vivant les
différentes esthétiques autour de
commission alors les commissions pour
attribuer des aides à son très longues
elles sont compliquées etc mais au moins
les gens se rencontrent commencent à
partager et sont et estiment que c'est
évidemment
un plus c'est donc se mérite qui est
souligné il y a des évolutions qui sont
nécessaires peut-être resserrées le
conseil d'administration peut-être
resserré un peu le canal des aides on a
identifié 40 aides différentes donc
travailler davantage sur leur australité
on y reviendra si vous le souhaitez il y
a des évolutions il faut applaudir le
CNM mais surtout il faut faire du CNM le
bras armé le levier pour cette nouvelle
stratégie ce que nous avons voulu
financer c'est une stratégie dont le CNM
serait l'outil l'instrument
principal et j'en viens donc au
financement pour essayer de ne pas être
trop long monsieur le Président et pour
laisser la place au débat donc nous
avons absolument tout regardé
sur toutes les esthétiques et tous les
tous les secteurs et tous les types de
contribution
alors d'abord on a regardé différentes
fiscalités l'attaque sur les objets
connectés et la taxe numérique
objectivement c'est très difficile vous
le lirez dans le rapport la taxe sur les
objets connectés ce serait une toute
petite taxe qui rapporterait très peu
les objets connectés ne servent pas qu'à
écouter de la musique c'est les
enceintes sous les écouteurs etc vous
pouvez écouter des podcasts avec vous
identifier mal la musique c'est très
compliqué à bâtir par ailleurs il y a la
copie privée sur le téléchargement etc
bon bref
c'est c'est une piste extrêmement
compliqué l'attaque sur le numérique
évidemment beaucoup d'acteurs rêveraient
de dire on va brancher sur cet axe qui
rapporte 650 millions d'euros etc mais
d'abord ce serait une première pour la
musique deuxièmement c'est une taxe qui
a vocation à ne pas être pérenne
puisqu'une fois que l'OCDE a repris le
sujet elle doit disparaître
troisièmement l'idée d'une affectation
avait plutôt été écarté dès le départ
bref c'est assez compliqué reste le
budgétaire mais le budgétaire dans le
contexte c'est extrêmement compliqué
rajouter voilà je vous ai pas donné le
montant mais on y reviendra 30 à 40
millions d'euros sur le CNM dans un
contexte budgétaire con tendu c'est
complexe et d'autant que ça ne répond
pas à la question des contributions des
différents acteurs donc ce que nous
proposons c'est une contribution sur ce
qui marche pas sur les radios qui sont
plutôt en baisse d'audience pas non plus
sur le CD mais sur le stream gratuit et
sur le stream payant une contribution
équitable qui part de ce qui existe sur
le spectacle vivant avec la billetterie
et donc de la même façon il y a une
contribution
qui est créé sur ce qui est extrêmement
dynamique nous proposons dans le même
temps de baisser le droit de tirage sur
le spectacle vivant le droit de tirage
le fait que sur la plaque billetterie à
trois et demi pour cent 65% on est rendu
les acteurs sont d'accord pour dire on
peut réduire un peu ça donne plus de
place vous êtes sélective et donc
ça fait un taux qui serait de 1,75
puisqu'en gros vous payez 3 et demi mais
on vous rend 1,75 de taxes
automatiquement sans aucune condition et
ce qui fait que il y aurait une
contribution élargie équitable de 1,75%
sur l'ensemble de de du secteur
spectacle vivant comme musique
enregistrée en tout cas sur sur le
stream dans le même temps nous estimons
que ce n'est pas le moment de revenir
sur les crédits d'impôts ils sont en
cours d'évaluation au CNM et donc dans
l'attente de cette évaluation nous
proposons de les prolonger parce qu'ils
ont fait la preuve de leur de leur
efficacité
cette solution permet de pérenniser un
acquis qui est le centre de la musique
qui permettra la musique d'avoir au son
centre national
réactif comme les autres industries
culturelles et qui soit financé en
rythme de croisière ça permet de mettre
tout le monde autour de la table quel
que soit le secteur puisque nous
proposons également d'étendre au
classique qui est dans le CNM mais qui
n'est pas dans la taxe billetterie et le
classique d'ailleurs la globalement
accepté j'y reviendrai et puis ça permet
de dire à chaque fois qu'il y a un canal
et bien on finance au fond c'est ce qui
a été réalisé pour le cinéma à chaque
fois qu'un nouveau carnaval est apparu
pour pouvoir avoir des recettes et en
souci d'équité et bien on a inventé la
façon dont il pourrait contribuer ça
reprend des principes bien établis Laval
finançant l'amont les catalogues anciens
financent le renouvellement et la
nouveauté et tout ça est équitablement
réparti la réception du rapport a été
assez puisque pour la première fois neuf
organisations syndicales ont signé
ensemble un soutien c'est inédit le
Prodis avec le SMA par exemple mais
également les forces musicales pour la
musique classique 9
organisations professionnelles restent
bien sûr les majors qui sont opposés je
signale que contrairement à d'autres
industries culturelles les majors aucune
nation centre de décision en France
puisque les trois grandes majors ce qui
est pas le cas pour le livre ou pour le
cinéma ce sujet différent mais pour la
musique il n'y a plus de majeur qui est
réellement un centre de décision je
dirais en France et puis
également des des retours parfois plus
divers sur tout ce qui tient évidemment
tout ce qui sont liés aux grands aux
grands producteurs
reste que le rapport conclu sur d'autres
sujets et notamment l'éducation musicale
que nous nous n'avons pas pu assez
aborder tous les acteurs nous ont parlé
mais c'est une autre mission en soi
c'est une autre mission parce que tout
ça passe d'abord par
davantage d'éducation musicale à l'école
notamment voilà pour vous faire une
présentation rapide
qui doit avoir une traduction dans le
PLF comme vous l'avez dit puisque à
partir du moment c'est une contribution
qui est proposée elle doit figurer au
PLF j'espère ne pas avoir été trop long
et avoir pu essayer de présenter des
principaux enjeux la présentation
initiale était importante pour que
chacun ait bien la dimension du rapport
je vais peut-être laisser la parole à
nos collègues qui souhaitent intervenir
et puis bien sûr vous vous interviendrez
si vous le souhaitez à travers vos
réponses en commençant par Jean Raymond
Hugonnet
merci président
bonjour mesdames messieurs
merci à Julien barjoton pour ce rapport
et à vous messieurs dames pour ce
rapport forcément très intéressant
nous voilà donc au rendez-vous trois ans
après
nous avons porté le CNM sur les fonds
bâtissements et si je reprends de
mémoire la deuxième première ou deuxième
phrase du propos introductif du rapport
sur la création du CNM nous avions mis
en avant le fait que les conditions
financières n'étaient pas prévues et que
c'était un écueil
nous y voilà donc aujourd'hui
alors j'ai toujours pour principe de
voir le verre à moitié plein plutôt qu'à
moitié vide donc on va se réjouir
avec un je vois de la cité un cœur
vraiment absolu pour
pour les résultats de ce rapport
diligenté par madame la ministre
quand on parle stratégie
forte ambition
j'ai toujours un peu peur chers
collègues c'est comme à chaque fois
qu'on parle de simplification
c'est-à-dire qu'on nous annonce des
choses
et infinies on se retrouve devant
quelque chose qui est assez maigre je ne
veux pas réduire le rapport de notre
excellent collègue Julien barjoton à la
création de taxes
puisque c'est bien de ça dont il s'agit
quand même
moi j'aurais souhaité justement que le
ministère puisse demander
une vision la suite du rapport et encore
une fois ce n'est pas péjoratif pour le
travail qui a été fait et que je salue
et pour la synthèse que tu en as fait
mais quand même si on se rappelle bien
les choses le CNM a été créé suite à
l'excellent rapport
de recoli biémestre il se trouve que
c'est le premier rapport que nous avons
eu après le renouvellement de 2017 que
nous avons eu à
regarder et à étudier dans cette
commission
ce rapport était assez limpide parce que
non seulement
il considérait l'écosystème de la
musique qui est en France très important
mais il considérait aussi et surtout la
matière première musique
et tu as terminé ton propos Julien par
cela
l'éducation musicale n'est pas traitée
et c'est à mon sens et encore une fois
ce n'est pas une pierre dans le jardin
mais en fait ça commence par là
la musique en France est un véritable
patrimoine il n'est pas considéré comme
tel pour quelle raison
la musique est en France quelque chose
qui a ses lettres de noblesse y compris
dans le droit d'auteur puisque les
droits d'auteurs sont un patrimoine
français
je ne peux pas comprendre
qu'on continue toujours à aborder ces
questions
bien entendu il y a ce qu'on appelle
péjorativement le business et il est
très important dans d'autres pays mais
il y a d'abord la matière première et
quelque chose que jamais personne ne
voudra réguler et qui s'appelle la
créativité
cette créativité
elle n'est pas forcément innée elle
s'acquiert aussi elle se travaille elle
se travaille par l'éducation musicale
alors une fois que j'ai dit ça
encore une fois
je me méfie beaucoup
des stratégies
ambitieuses parce que je l'ambition je
ne la vois pas je vois précisément ici
le moyen de financer quelque chose qui
n'a pas été prévu initialement et devant
lequel nous nous sentons bien dépourvu
aujourd'hui
Alfort il faut régler bien évidemment ce
problème
essayez d'éviter ce qui est un mal
constant dans la musique
le nombre d'auditions le révèle
c'est un milieu qui est totalement
dispersé dans lesquels les intérêts les
confrontations changent en fonction de
l'âge des personnes concernées puisque
les mêmes qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui
j'en parle à l'aise derrière
la table dans les auditions je pourrais
faire le profil qu'ils avaient il y a 30
ans ou 40 ans quand ils avaient d'autres
positions et bizarrement ces positions
changent chers collègues et elle change
en fonction de quoi elle change en
fonction du business que crée et que
génère la musique alors tout à l'heure
et je serai pas beaucoup plus long parce
que c'est plus une remarque à la limite
qu'une question
tu as cité et c'est tout à fait
révélateur on peut même en citer un
troisième actuellement qui est
totalement
tenu sous silence des avocats qui s'en
occupent tu as parlé de Bob Dylan et de
Bruce Springsteen le boss qui ont vendu
leurs droits pour 500 millions de
dollars et l'un et l'autre et ils savent
compter
je vous engage à regarder ce qui se
passe autour de Pink Floyd dans le
fondateur vient de donner un excellent
concert la semaine dernière
il fait un peu trop de politique par
rapport à la musique ça reste quand même
un génie du 21e siècle mais quel que
soit les valivernes qu'il puisse
proférer mais
mais quand même là ça va être quelque
chose parce qu'il se trouve que les
membres du groupe se détestent
joyeusement et s'il se déteste forcément
c'est aussi à cause de problèmes
financier il y en a un qui vient à Paris
le 31 mai que je vous engage à aller
voir qui s'appelle John Fogerty qui
était le fondateur de Creedence
Clearwater Revival qui lui a fait juste
le contraire
au bout de 50 ans d'un travail parce que
c'est un passionné parce que c'est un
musicien sait et ça restera même à 77
ans un Créateur infini il a racheté les
droits de ces musiques parce qu'il les
considère comme un patrimoine et qu'il
préfère en être lui le propriétaire et
le garant ce qu'une maison de disque
scandaleusement avait empêché de faire
quand il a signé son premier contrat
musique et business c'est un parallèle
certes et ces travaux font avancer les
choses dans le bon sens on est encore
loin du compte à mon sens
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
tout d'abord je voudrais saluer le
travail le rapport de notre collègue
Julien bargenteau ainsi que Madame et
messieurs voilà
qu'ils l'ont accompagné dans la
rédaction de ce rapport
il était bienvenu puisque vous vous
souvenez qu'aux dernières à la dernière
loi de finances on s'était posé la
question de toute façon du CNM et de son
financement et que les fameux 20
millions d'euros qui étaient en suspens
et qui manquait selon les dires de de
son directeur il allait les trouver pour
passer l'année 2023 mais il y avait une
vraie question sur l'année 2024 donc ce
rapport amène et apporte un certain
nombre de propositions budgétaires et je
pense que c'était quand même la finalité
qui était demandée à l'issue de ce
rapport pour pouvoir faire des des
propositions qui d'ailleurs sont d'ordre
législatif de mon point de vue puisque
forcément si
la ministre de la Culture prend à son
compte la proposition d'une taxe sur le
streaming donc gratuit enfin tout ce qui
a évoqué notre collègue il va falloir
passer par par la loi donc c'était une
première question mais en tout cas moi
je voudrais vraiment saluer saluer ce
rapport il est extrêmement intéressant
parce que au-delà des questions
budgétaires et d'ailleurs je le dis
aussi parce que c'est souvent mes propos
en tant que rapporteur pour avis la
question des crédits d'impôts de leur
évaluation et de leur demande de
prolongation est aussi un point très
important dans le rapport et je veux le
souligner parce que c'est toujours un de
plus en plus en tout cas une bataille
que nous avons dans le cadre des
préparations de la loi de finances donc
vraiment à la fois sur le fond de ces
propositions qui étaient qui étaient
attendus et sur un certain nombre de
recommandations et notamment sur les
crédits d'impôts je ne peux en tout cas
que saluer
vraiment les les préconisations de de
notre collègue
elles sont d'autant plus importantes
qu'elles s'appuie sur effectivement une
vision stratégique
avec ces différents points sur
l'exportation sur les indépendants tout
ce qu'il a été dit et je trouverai
vraiment intéressant pour pour de toute
façon dans les mois et années à venir
pouvoir continuer à avoir une veille et
intervenir sur le secteur qui est en
constant on voit bien évolution et qui
est impacté en permanence par voilà le
contexte qu'il soit national et surtout
international alors je n'aurais pas des
regrets parce que je pense que ça
n'était pas mais il me le dira dans sa
lettre de mission mais je voudrais lui
poser quelques questions
parce que
j'ai je l'ai lu et je ne crois pas qu'il
est fait référence ou en tout cas je
voudrais lui demander plus précisément
son avis chers Julien et notamment sur
la question de ce qu'on appelle marqueur
marketing et le user centric
qui est donc vous savez la rémunération
donc de l'artiste
lié pour le premier point à l'audience
globale donc au marché et pour le
deuxième point à l'écoute personnelle en
fait de chaque utilisateur donc ces deux
systèmes et je voudrais
avoir ton point de vue sur sur le sujet
est-ce qu'il faut faire évoluer le
système de rémunération lié aux écoutes
sur les plateformes de streaming c'est à
dire passer du Market à user centric ou
pas est-ce que ça aurait une incidence
est-ce qu'on a mesuré l'impact est-ce
que qu'en pense finalement les acteurs
je ne crois pas avoir vu de point de vue
sur ce sujet là qui est quand même très
important parce que quand on pense à la
rémunération d'un artiste sur un marché
préalablement défini on voit bien
aujourd'hui ce qui sort comme titre et
comme esthétique musicale donc bon c'est
vraiment une une cette question que que
je pose pas obligatoirement d'avis sur
le sujet mais j'aimerais bien avoir ton
avis la deuxième c'est
j'ai été assez surprise de parce que
c'est principalement axé sur le secteur
marchand de ne pas finalement avoir
quand même une réflexion sur le secteur
on va dire non marchand c'est à dire sur
la notion de filière et sur l'impact en
termes de politique publique et
j'entends vers ce qu'on dit aujourd'hui
et ce que les acteurs eux-mêmes
reconnaissent la question de la
production et de la diffusion produire
mieux pour diffuser mieux on va dire et
du coup les impacts en termes de
politique publique que ça peut que ça
peut induire lié aussi à toute la
réflexion qui est dans le dans le
secteur de la filière de transition
écologique qui est aussi un des impacts
sur le modèle économique qui est aussi
va avoir des impacts sur les territoires
en matière forcément d'intervention des
collectivités territoriales qui
interviennent beaucoup quand même sur
sur l'ensemble de l'écosystème musical
je suis dans une ville je sais pour
avoir suivi en tant qu'élu les Trans
Musicales depuis sa création j'ai vu
toutes l'évolution du secteur et c'est
un laboratoire extrêmement intéressant
ce festival parce qu'il y a aucune tête
d'affiche donc il ne repose que sur la
façon dont le secteur évolue via
indépendant via filière via aujourd'hui
toutes l'évolution du marché pour
pouvoir quand même tenir derrière un
mode un modèle économique qui est un
modèle public donc je je trouve qu'il
aurait été intéressant mais peut-être
c'est la prochaine étape je ne sais pas
de montrer qu'à travers ce CNM se pose
aussi des questions de politiques
publiques au-delà des questions d'être
sélectif des commissions qui sont à
l'oeuvre des festivals etc mais pour
montrer vraiment comment et je
terminerai là
un contexte qui est quand même lié à un
phénomène de concentration important
peut aussi impacter
des politiques publiques et une filière
qui est fragilisée sur certains de ces
de ces segments et qui peut-être du coup
aurait besoin du CNM et des politiques
publiques pour pouvoir un moment être
plus équilibré ce qu'aujourd'hui on voit
quand même des déséquilibres dans la
filière qui sont assez qui sont assez
inquiétants voilà merci beaucoup en tout
cas de ce rapport extrêmement documenté
intéressant et merci pour vos travaux
Catherine Moret de saillie
merci monsieur le Président à mon tour
de féliciter le rapporteur quand on
examine la liste des personnes
auditionnées en mesure l'ampleur du
travail qui a été conduit ces dernières
semaines donc bravo ça sera un document
utile à partager pour pouvoir en effet
tel que cela a été dit disposé d'une
stratégie forte pour la musique en
France il était temps il était temps
mais malheureusement
l'énonciation cette stratégie
j'ai la même remarque que mon collègue
Jean Raymond Hugo D est incomplète parce
qu'il manque cette partie si importante
que constitue l'éducation les
enseignements et la formation artistique
je rappellerai très brièvement que de la
question des conservatoires est toujours
en berne le système est complètement
thrombosé la décentralisation est en
panne malgré nos nous votes n'est ce pas
cher Sylvie Robert de la loi de 2017
origine bachois beau qui le système sur
des schémas régionaux d'enseignement
artistique proposée par des régions elle
n'a pas opéré le transfert des
financements donc il y a il y a un vrai
sujet qui va falloir
relancer la formation c'est je partage
la remarque de Julien barjetton c'est un
sujet d'avenir pour l'ensemble des des
musiques donc les conservatoires plutôt
musique de patrimoine et création mais
il y a la formation liée au musiques
actuelles le rôle des collectivités
notamment des régions est très important
dans la structuration de cette cuillère
comme ça l'est pour le cinéma et et le
livre maintenant je pense que une
réflexion également sur la
décentralisation dans ce domaine là
mériterait d'être conduite pour plus
d'efficacité de réactivité autour des
agences qui sont constitués en région
pour développer la filière en lien avec
le CNM ça c'est la chose nouvelle et
extrêmement
positive mais je crois encore une fois
qu'on a encore un chantier à mener sur
la base de la remarque faite par le le
rapporteur de de la mission
ce sur quoi je voudrais insister c'est
que si les tout à fait louable de
vouloir avoir un plan pour l'ensemble
des musiques et rapprocher l'ensemble
des genres et les musiques dans cette
stratégie du CNAM il ne faudrait pas
oublier la spécificité j'avais
l'occasion de le dire je viens par le
temps qu'il m'avait dit la spécificité
de la musique de patrimoine et de
création ce sont nos orchestres nos
opéras qui sont des structures publiques
en réalité qui mènent des missions de
service public essentiellement financées
par les collectivités territoriales pour
les pour les deux tiers et par le
ministère et qui dépendent de
financement direct de la direction
générale de la création artistique donc
on a en somme un paysage avec la
constitution de l'agence d'un côté qui
agit sur différents secteurs dans
différents dispositifs très utiles à
l'ensemble du secteur il faut bien le
dire mais on a cette spécificité et
aujourd'hui on ne voit toujours pas et
on a pas besoin de la parole de la
ministre parce qu'on ne voit toujours
pas comment les les deux vont
s'articuler je crois qu'il y a une
demande forte du secteur d'avoir une
clarification de manière constructive
de manière à ce que cette agence elle
soit bien le bras armée du ministère
pour l'établissement de l'ensemble de la
stratégie musicale et ça ce point reste
à clarifier
je crois qu'il est un peu hâtif de dire
que tout le monde est d'accord sur
l'établissement de la taxe sur la
billetterie je le dis parce que si le
syndicat des forces musicales en effet à
manifester son intérêt à souligner
d'ailleurs l'excellent travail les
associations
réunions des opéras de France
association française qui représente non
seulement les directeurs
d'établissements mais les élus qui
financent les financeurs les tutelles je
crois que celle-ci n'ont pas été
consultés or je pense que France urbaine
région de France dans une moindre mesure
département de France vont devoir être
consultés je le dis et j'arrête parce
que s'il faut trouver les modes de
financement pour CNR on est bien
d'accord
la question budgétaire est vraiment très
très sensible en ce moment vous avez vu
le nombre de scènes et de salles qui
sont en train de fermer de réduire le
proclamation ils sont pris de plein
fouet par la crise économique le coût de
l'énergie
les collectivités n'ont pas de marge de
manœuvre puisqu'elles n'ont plus de
levier fiscal avec la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation pour augmenter leur
financement à ces structures elles font
de leur mieux
le ministère a maintenu c'est c'est
financements et agit ici et là pour
aider ponctuellement à des difficultés
liées au coup de de l'énergie mais le
secteur est extrêmement fragilisé donc
une taxe sur la billetterie aujourd'hui
il faut qu'elle soit compensées par
autre chose et je ne vois pas d'autres
solutions qu'actuellement et soit
composées par le la hausse du coût du
billet et de l'entrée dans le cadre de
politique publique où on s'efforce
d'avoir des tarifications les plus
attractifs possibles bon mais tout ça
mérite détendez pas bien entendu mais
voilà je crois que il faut qu'on mesure
bien
voilà qu'on avance plus prudemment sur
sur ce sujet dernier point je l'évoquais
avec j'aurais moduler parce que je me
souviens des débats qui ont présidé la
création du Sénat et notamment la
composition de son conseil
d'administration sa gouvernance je pense
qu'on aurait intérêt à revenir si on
pouvait sur la représentation justement
des collectivités territoriales
auxquelles on a demandé de se mettre
d'accord département région ville pour
désigner un représentant conjugué à la
parité je ne vous raconte pas la
difficulté ce qui fait que les sièges
sont vides on n'arrive pas à se mettre
d'accord on a mis deux ans avant de
dessiner quelqu'un donc je pense qu'il y
a peut-être quelque chose si on veut
qu'elle soit partie prenante d'une
dynamique qui se constitue je pense
qu'il y aurait quelque chose à
simplifier de ce côté là voilà merci
monsieur le rapporteur Céline Brulin
merci président merci pour cette
présentation qui je trouve
identifie bien à la fois l'éclatement du
secteur le fait que la musique ne se
soit pas doté d'une stratégie collective
comme d'autres domaines vous avez évoqué
le cinéma et le livre notamment et puis
sur le fait que le Centre national de la
musique a joué son rôle
face au covid qui quand même a percuté
un peu sa création et ça n'a pas été
tout à fait anodin mais qu'il y a
maintenant besoin qu'il s'engage dans
une nouvelle offensive je sais pas si on
peut le dire comme ça avec nos collègues
ont eu raison de leur rappeler ce que
nous avions identifié ici dès le départ
c'est un problème de financement
originel dans la conception qui en avait
été alors je ne voudrais pas dire que
notre collègue Hugonnet m'a enlevé les
mots de la bouche
dans tout le couplet qu'il a développé
sur musique et business j'ai trouvé pour
mais peut-être j'ai eu une oreille un
peu sélective que vous avez
entamer pratiquement la présentation de
votre rapport sur
la musique
comme stratégie d'influence or je trouve
que le rapport est beaucoup plus riche
et beaucoup plus complet
que ce que vous en avez présenté en tout
cas l'entame que vous en avez faite mais
encore une fois j'ai peut-être eu une
oreille sélective
c'est un rapport qui a été plutôt bien
accueilli je trouve et que nous
accueillons ici aussi de manière avec
quand même quelques bémol je vais pas
redire pour ce qui vient d'être dit à la
fois par Sylvie Robert et Catherine
Morin de saillie sur quelques écueils à
éviter dans le contexte notamment
budgétaire des collectivités avec cette
proposition de taxes
spectacle en revanche
moi je l'accueille d'un très bon œil
latex streaming
qui permet
pas à dire du ruissellement mais quand
même un partage de la valeur qui serait
réparti plus équitablement et qui
pourrait justement permettre de
développer ce qu'on attend les uns et
les autres ma question c'est un peu
parce qu'on a vu que les major commencer
à s'y opposer alors pas forcément d'une
manière très frontale ou très vindicatif
mais quand même on connaît leur capacité
d'influencer
on sait ça a été évoqué que ça doit
passer par un PLF je pense qu'on est un
certain nombre ici à pouvoir
peser dans le bon sens pour que cette
taxe voit le jour mais vous qui en savez
certainement beaucoup plus que nous
pouvez-vous nous dire quelle est la
chance de vie et d'advenir de cet axe
de rajouter quelques questions aussi
pour notre compréhension vous avez dit
que vous avez buté on comprend bien sur
la difficulté d'avoir des chiffres ce
qui jamais très facile du reste pour
analyser un secteur et puis concevoir le
financement d'une structure quand on a
on n'a pas les données
quelques questions de précision alors
pour notre compréhension d'abord je
rebondis par rapport à une remarque de
Sylvie Robert nous nous avions plutôt le
chiffre en tête pour les besoins du CMN
de l'ordre d'une vingtaine de millions
là vous êtes plutôt sur 40 bon on dirait
s'il y a 20 millions de plus ça ne peut
que renforcer l'action du du CNM mais
comment vous êtes arrivés à ce chiffre
est-ce que c'est justement par
identification des besoins ou au
contraire c'est le raisonnement qui
semble se deviner et de dessiner 20
millions sur la taxe streaming 6
millions
sur les des
OGC enfin bref le plan tu as décrit tout
à l'heure
deuxième question toujours sur ces
données financières bon en soit on se
dit compte tenu de la vitalité du
secteur qui est un secteur qui se porte
bien financièrement
corrigera si tu n'as pas la même maladie
mais
20 millions c'est pas grand chose est-ce
que vous pourriez quand même nous donner
quelques ordres de grandeur 20 millions
sur le streaming par rapport à la
chiffre d'affaires du de du stream
qu'est-ce que ça représente et question
sans doute plus difficile mais elle est
importante quel serait l'effet de la
création de cet axe et du montant
prélevé
tu as indiqué Julien tout à l'heure dans
ton propos préalable un chiffre
important que moi j'avais pas du tout à
l'esprit que 70% des revenus du
streaming sont en fait reversés
aux ayant droit est-ce que du coup c'est
20 millions ça se traduit par une
augmentation de de des tarifs qui sont
bas d'ailleurs de de d'abonnement assez
plateformes ou est-ce que c'est un effet
un peu de potentiellement aussi dans ce
sens là sur les différents
ayons droits et puis dernière question
qui n'est pas en lien avec ces questions
financières mais qui apparaît dans en
conclusion il y a une petite phrase
sibyline que vous avez rajouté qui n'est
certainement pas anodine et qui n'était
pas me semble-t-il dans les dans la
lettre de mission sur la gouvernance
vous avez glissé à la fin que la
gouvernance doit être réinterroger alors
comme vous arrêtez là on est évidemment
en manque en disant et je profite de
votre présence aux uns et aux autres
pour que vous nous disiez en quoi ce
gouvernance doit être réinterroger
alors je vais je vais merci beaucoup je
vais répondre à cette série de questions
puis je laisserai mes collègues
l'inspecteurs complété alors
c'est vrai que je voulais faire une
présentation bref mais cher Jean Raymond
le rapport insiste beaucoup sur
l'écosystème la matière musicale les
évolutions les droits vous avez tableau
sur les droits d'auteur vous avez les
répartitions de chiffre d'affaires etc
donc et c'est vraiment l'a dit aussi
j'ai voulu insister sur la stratégie ce
qui me paraissait être la stratégie
adéquate mais il y a toute cette toute
cette description qui est bien qui est
bien dans le rapport
et je partage ton vraiment ton point de
vue sur la dispersion la confrontation
le fait que des gens dans leur carrière
changent de position etc tout ça on l'a
constaté à 100% donc je peux que te et
d'ailleurs je pense que ça explique
aussi la situation dans laquelle on est
c'est une situation collective oui
l'éducation musicale vous l'avez tous
cité je cite à la fin malheureusement ça
n'était pas l'objet du rapport de
l'omission et ça faisait trop il fait
déjà 50 pages 50 pages d'annexes
repartir sur les conservatoires qui est
un sujet en tant que tel donc c'est pour
ça que j'écris tel quel qu'il faudrait
une autre mission ou une autre parce que
c'était vraiment c'était pas possible
mais on l'a rencontré à tout à tous les
niveaux
le fait vous avez plusieurs revenus sur
le lieu de création d'une taxe on l'a
fait récemment sur Netflix par exemple
ça pas créer un cataclysme dans les
plateformes audiovisuelles et ça ça a
pas eu non plus d'effet sur la le
financement de la production en France
ni même ni même sur sur les prix la
forte ambition vous avez vu des
commentaires aussi sur
que ce soit Catherine que ce soit toi
Jean Raymond Céline etc
vraiment quand je suis rentré je suis
rentré par la lettre de mission mais au
bout d'un moment dans les analyses on
s'est vraiment dur on s'est vraiment
rendu compte et on peut je te remercie
de dire que c'est complémentaire il y a
pas que ça mais que ce secteur avait
besoin d'une ambition d'une ambition
très forte quand on dit influence etc
c'est de dire est-ce que comme le font
d'autres pays on peut pas on choisit 10
12 15 articles dans un ensemble etc
qu'on décide de promouvoir pour la
France chaque année etc c'est un exemple
est-ce que on peut pas se mettre
d'accord pour affronter ensemble et
s'approprier les innovations qui
perturbent le système donc c'est pas du
tout réducteur mais c'est vraiment
l'idée de ne pas partir de finalement
des d'un financement de du sujet de
contribution etc mais de dire mais de
quoi a-t-on besoin aujourd'hui pour la
musique française je pense qu'on a
besoin de continuer à corriger les
personnes de marché comme nous le
faisons et dès le renouvellement et des
territoires et des les esthétiques en
difficulté classique musique du monde
jazz etc donc et ça c'est les politiques
publiques classiques notamment matières
culturelles mais aussi
vraiment structuré autour d'une nouvelle
stratégie et le CNM puisqu'il est créé
il doit avoir un rythme de croisière il
doit être l'outil qui fait les deux et
il doit être financé pour le faire ça
c'est vraiment ma conviction
personnelle et sur sur le sujet
sur le les financements
donc les finalités où il y a l'ordre
législatif bien sûr c'est dans
législatif Sylvie tu as tu as tout à
fait raison merci pour ce que tu dis sur
les crédits d'impôts
marketing qui gère centré qu'on y fait
référence on ne se prononce pas je suis
pas sûr que ce soit au rôle de la
puissance publique en tant que telle de
se prononcer il y a une étude du CNM en
revanche ce qu'on dit sur le manque du
rôle d'observatoire c'est qu'il y a eu
des études un peu contradictoires en
Allemagne il y a des secteurs qui disent
non non ça déplacerait de 10 ou 15% mais
pour le classique 10 ou 15% de plus
c'est beaucoup donc
moi je pense pas que ce soit un
parlementaire ou même staradois ou de la
puissance publique de dire parce que ça
ça concerne finalement le fonctionnement
de cette industrie mais en revanche si
on était davantage outillés en
transparence de données en étude mieux
armée je pense et avec des comparaisons
internationales un peu plus établies ça
ferait partie du rôle du CNM justement
peut-être pour le refaire le revoir
mettre d'accord tout le monde construire
cette maison commune et choisir une
option je pense que ça fait partie de ça
pour l'instant on a des acteurs comme
certaines plateformes qui disent ben
nous on va passer directement à l'usure
centric mais c'est vrai que d'ailleurs
les gens qu'on interroge sont persuadés
que ils payent chacun les artistes qui
écoutent ce qui n'est pas le tout le cas
mais c'est contre-intuitif mais c'est
c'est le cas tu es plus critique sur la
partie de nos machins en filière j'ai
peut-être pas assez insisté encore une
fois là-dessus dans ma présentation
c'est bon à savoir mais il y a beaucoup
de choses sur les contrats de filière
dans le rapport on on insiste beaucoup
sur le volet territorial sur notamment
ce qui est fait en Aquitaine avec le
partage des compétences avec le fait
qu'il y a eu la transition écologique
l'égalité femme homme comme comme axe
transverso de ses contrats de filière de
ses conventions qui sont signés par
exemple avec Clermont-Ferrand avec
d'autres villes etc donc vraiment on
insiste énormément sur l'évolution du
spectacle vivant les festivals tout ça
tout ça figure dans dans le rapport
également mais je partage il y a tout ce
secteur là et le fait de maintenir la
diversité est-ce que j'ai toujours des
grands festivals c'est pas c'est pas
choquant qui des grands festivals la
vérité de d'affiches mais il faut aussi
des festivals qui permettent l'émergence
et des festivals qui soient pour des
chanteurs qui sont parfois en milieu de
carrière dont on parle pas souvent et
c'est pour qui c'est pas le plus simple
parce que parfois entre l'émergence et
puis les grandes stars il y a un peu
comme pour les films du milieu comme on
dit au cinéma il y a le milieu de
carrière qui est parfois extrêmement
compliqué pour certains artistes
critique c'est on voit aujourd'hui que
les contrats d'artistes sont en train
d'exploser vraiment vous avez des
retours j'imagine de directeur de
festival sur l'été et même pour les
Vieilles Charrues qui est quand même un
festival et qui se j'ai eu informations
des montants de contrats d'artistes
c'est juste inadmissible mais c'est même
inadmissible et c'est ça que je disais
c'est qu'à un moment derrière il y a
aussi une réflexion en termes de
politique publique quand on soutient des
festivals en l'occurrence celui-là il
est pas soutenu par la puissance
publique mais je parlais des trans tout
à l'heure ou un moment l'effet impactant
de l'environnement
interroge la puissance publique et
Catherine nous disait très justement
dans un
contexte de contrainte des budgets des
collectivités qui pour la plupart c'est
surtout ça que je donc d'où la veille il
a l'air l'observation et et l'évolution
de la filière voilà c'était seulement à
cet endroit là que je pour Catherine je
partage bien sûr l'éducation la
formation malheureusement bon c'était
difficile de l'aborder le rapprochement
plus classique moi je crois que c'est
comme une forme d'une force du CNM il
faut que ce soit la maison de toutes les
musiques ça c'est un acquis et ils
comprennent la musique classique qui a
bénéficié d'aide
sans aujourd'hui contribuer alors je
sais bien que la taxe billetterie c'est
un sujet c'est 5 à 6 millions attendus
je note que alors ce sont des
journalistes mais il y a diapason ou
France Musique ont extrêmement bien reçu
l'idée de pouvoir avoir une contribution
du classique il y aurait le droit de
tirage certes à 50% mais le classique
s'il rentre dans la taxe il bénéficiera
au même moment au même montant de droit
de tirage les cinémas il y a une taxe
billetterie que vous soyez un cinéma
municipal un cinéma éco enfin voilà de
l'économie sociale et solidaire un
cinéma associatif un cinéma etc il y a
toujours la taxe billetterie pour toutes
les formes les smacks sont aidés par les
collectivités locales par l'état non non
mais il y a la musique nouvelle sont
aidées et elles ont quand même la taxe
sur sur la billetterie et si tu as là où
tu as raison je te remercie de dire
qu'il faut ouvrir le débat c'est sans
préjugé bien sûr d'un soutien de ce
qu'on fait sur les opéras et les
orchestres et notamment de de ce
deuxième temps d'une de voir comment on
travaille ensemble et là aussi
collectivement mutualisant réfléchissant
sur la musique classique en France mais
c'est une réflexion plus globale mais je
pense que c'est important que si on dit
c'est un outil stratégique d'ensemble il
faut qu'il y ait le classique et
paradoxalement je sais bien qu'elle
débat sur les orchestres et les opéras
mais le classique attend plutôt de dire
on est autour de la table on a bénéficié
d'aide on nous critique nous on est
allant on veut y aller on veut voir
comment on veut être aidé mais on veut
plutôt participer à une stratégie
collective Céline
[Musique]
oui la chance de faire à prospérer au
passage j'ai répondu sur les autres
sujets
c'est la majorité précédente qui a mis
en place la taxe Netflix la contribution
Netflix et qu'il a augmenté à 5,15 on
parle pas de 1,75 on est à 5,15 avec en
plus les obligations de production
française ça n'a pas entraîné une hausse
des prix de l'abonnement ma conviction
c'est que les abonnements que ce soit
pour le stream etc sont fixés par des
stratégies mondiales de grands groupes
c'est ils disent pas uniquement en
fonction de ça c'est des choix européens
etc donc pour répondre aussi à Laurent
comme je suis Président je crois pas un
effet 1,75 ça correspond à 15 centimes
17 centimes par abonnement donc je veux
dire c'est absorbable dans ce coin une
légère hausse pour le consommateur pour
les majors dont on voit le prix auquel
ils achètent les catalogues sur les
rachète pour des voilà les
intermédiaires franchement 15 centimes
par abonnement
c'est extrêmement extrêmement abordable
les 40 millions ils viennent vraiment
d'une identification des besoins le
rapport boitcario déjà 10 millions en
plus pour l'exportation nous on dit
aujourd'hui la concurrence est encore
plus grande entre temps on a perdu une
place bon donc il faut aller voilà et le
rapport roquevilliersmes les différents
rapports en parler les sujets sur
l'innovation nous ont été cités je
rencontrais Jean-Michel Jarre etc qui
m'en a beaucoup parlé donc c'est des
sujets qui préoccupent énormément la
filière et on se dit pour faire effet
levier à un moment on a calculé aussi
par rapport à ce qui existe et c'est
donc ensuite qu'on a construit une
proposition de financement d'une
stratégie dont le CNM est le bras armé
la gouvernance tu parlais du
collectivité locale vous en avez parlé
monsieur le président
moi j'ai plutôt la conviction mais ça
c'est en débat j'ai pas envie d'imposer
un truc je pense que les modèles de ou
les avec de CA plus restreint et de
conseil
tes conseils professionnels qui
fonctionnent bien qui se réunissent plus
souvent élargie mon avis c'est plus
efficace je pense que le modèle CNC avec
un conseil d'administration extrêmement
une commission de vie de Chavan qui
rassemble beaucoup de monde pourrait
inspirer pour réinspirer également le
CNM parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on a
rencontré des gens effectivement ils
nous ont demandé d'avoir un siège au
conseil d'administration en disant
pourquoi c'était l'organisation et pas
Intel il y a le sujet sur les
collectivités locales il y a d'autres
sujets avec avec d'autres types de
secteurs à chaque fois des
représentations il a déjà 27 membres si
je dis pas de bêtises c'est ça
c'est bon donc un conseil
d'administration après à 30-35 etc on
peut resserrer un conseil administration
et qui associe très bien les personnes
du secteur via les commissions réduites
efficaces et qui et qui produisent et
puis un conseil professionnel qui est
vraiment là pour préparer le conseil
d'administration de façon régulière et
active voilà plutôt ma préconisation
mais
elle sera elle est aussi dans le débat
et là aussi il y a quelques éléments
législatifs dans ce qu'on propose sur le
rôle du CNM voilà notamment on revient
pas sur ces missions mais il a quand
même 12 missions et donc il y a quand
même une façon de dire aussi que il faut
qu'il se concentre sur certaines sur
certaines dimensions
si vous voulez rajouter parce que les
autres
n'hésitez pas peut-être monsieur le
Président
[Musique]
vous aviez une question assez précise
sur le passage du chiffre de 20 millions
à
un ordre de grandeur qui serait plus
proche de 40 millions alors c'est
évidemment pas un pilotage par la
recette parce que le résultat auquel on
parvient pour pour l'hypothèse de taxe
et autour de 38 40 millions simplement
le CNM lui-même dès 2021 de manière
assez prudentielle à imaginer un budget
qui serait son budget pérenne en dehors
de toutes les aides exceptionnelles
qu'il avait pu
contribuer à
à accorder à l'ensemble de la filière
pendant la période de crise sanitaire
qui était autour de 38 millions de
budget d'intervention c'est-à-dire en
gros
une
programme d'aide minimale mais qui lui
semblait le minimum pour répondre à
l'ensemble des missions que la loi lui
des 12 missions que la loi lui a conféré
et par exemple dans cette épure
budgétaire on était toujours sur une
aide à l'export qui était comparable à
celle du burex avant la création du CNM
donc
l'idée de développer une stratégie
ciblée vers l'export vers l'innovation
ce sont des besoins nouveaux mais qui
ont été observés par la mission et qui
demande effectivement des financements
nécessaires et l'importance du chiffrage
pour l'export encore une fois qu'il y
avait déjà été bien souligné par le
rapport bois on est autour de 15
millions d'euros et l'innovation
actuellement c'est quand même le CNC qui
est très en pointe sur l'innovation et
qui est obligé d'ailleurs finalement de
prendre en charge aussi en partie de
l'univers musical je rappelle que c'est
Jean-Michel Jarre qui dirigent la
commission dédiée à l'innovation
numérique au CNC et il est assez
paradoxal que la musique comme comme l'a
dit le sénateur qui est traversé de
manière très importante par un ensemble
d'innovations liées à la révolution
numérique
ne soit pas en mesure ni même de guider
et d'accompagner les professionnels dans
cette transition
peut-être le chiffre d'affaires le
rapport sur le chiffre d'affaires vous
l'avez retrouvé le chiffre d'affaires
Guillaume
donc le chiffre d'affaires de la musique
enregistrée c'est de l'ordre de 900
millions d'euros en France et un peu
plus des deux tiers sont d'origine du
streaming payant et gratuit et il faut
savoir que dans les ventes physiques
c'est quand même encore 30% des revenus
avec une espèce de d'effet ciseaux
favorable entre le vinyle qui a des
progressions spectaculaires et le CD le
CD qui s'affaisse donc on est sur le sur
la partie streaming il faut ensuite
avoir un sénat de recomposition parce
que encore une fois on a dû beaucoup
bricoler parce qu'il y a aucun chiffre
qui est connu par la puissance publique
aucun
aucun et donc sur le le streaming on a
les chiffres publiés des revenus perçus
par les producteurs qu'on recompose avec
le 70% etc sur les profils de streaming
il y a une annexe qui qui dessine un peu
les choses qui sont faites mais par
exemple sur les questions de user
centric versus market centric le CN
avait fait une étude qui de leur avis
propre n'a pas pu aller jusqu'au bout
encore une fois parce qu'il manque des
choses on comprend que que
les plateformes se posent la question
mais la question de l'observation qui
est cité énormément la sœur tu as une
difficulté c'est là aussi ou la
comparaison avec avec le CNC
t’intéressante puisque on dit mais
finalement vous savez tout comment vous
faites les informations remontent
d'elles-mêmes c'est-à-dire qu'elles
remontent d'elle-même parce que les gens
demandent des aides ou elles remontent
d'elle-même puisqu'il y a une taxe
fiscale et donc quand il y a une taxe il
y a des informations qui remontent et le
CNM en est conscient mais c'est aussi
pour ça que le il y a ce point qui était
beaucoup par monsieur le sénateur qui
était la question de la stratégie c'est
qu'il y a un risque de saupoudrage le
CNM a grandi dans un contexte de crise
et associe très bien les professionnels
a su pendant la crise développée des
dispositifs de soutien les adapter etc
le risque si on pose que la question du
financement c'est de dire en fait on va
continuer à fragmenter une filière qui
est déjà fragmentée dans sa structure
était aussi fragmentée dans ses soutiens
publics donc il faut pas tout faire
remonter au CNM mais c'est sans doute le
rôle du CNM d'avoir quelque chose qui
est sans doute avec un effet de levier
plus fort et je me permets juste de
souligner ce merci beaucoup pour vos
questions c'est très agréable de voir
que le rapport suscite tout cet intérêt
un certain nombre des points que vous
avez suligner qui était peu abordés dans
le propos littéraire c'est en fait des
choses qui marchent bien c'est à dire
que finalement le soutien à la musique
patrimoniale il existe il existe depuis
longtemps il existe à différents niveaux
avec une implication très forte des
collectivités territoriales et c'est
plutôt quelque chose qui fonctionne là
où le discours sur le la partie
marchande c'est qu'il peut y avoir un
discours de certains acteurs qui
consiste à dire soutenez la musique
classique parce qu'elle en a besoin un
livraja et laissez-nous faire du
business tranquille et c'est là où
monsieur barjoton a juste titre dit en
fait c'est pas si simple et on peut
quand même vouloir faire les choses
intelligemment on peut vouloir dire
qu'il y a un besoin de redistribution
puisque les choses qui marchent elles
bénéficient aussi un moment d'émergence
elle bénéficie de soutien public et donc
c'est pas c'est pas absurde qui est une
forme de recirculation c'est pas absurde
de mettre la filière autour de la table
pour dire ben vous avez des intérêts
communs et donc et bien vous allez aller
dans le même sens et sur l'action
territoriale c'est la même chose on peut
aller plus loin on le dit dans le
rapport on incite à aller plus loin mais
les contrats de filière qui sont quelque
chose qui est vraiment sur mesure à
chaque fois qui existait déjà du centre
du temps du Centre national des variétés
mais qui a pris une composante beaucoup
plus puissante avec le CNL avec là aussi
une volonté du CNM de d'aller assez loin
puisque originalement c'est vraiment
pensé pour les régions mais avec
certains départements avec certaines
métropoles qui étaient très allant ils
ont fait des choses sur mesure
identifier
des plans d'action beaucoup sur l'emploi
beaucoup sur la transmission de savoir
et là encore quelque chose qui soit qui
soit le plus souple et le plus le plus
intelligent possible
sur l'observation Julien a raison de
soulier le graveur d'observation c'est
souligné par tous les professionnels de
la musique donc on a un immense chantier
à travers dessus le soutien à
l'exportation à la circulation
à la
au déplacement etc c'est très important
aussi c'est une extrêmement bonne
remarque dans le principe aussi du
respect de développement durable parce
qu'on a ces questions écologiques à
prendre en compte donc je voulais juste
dire Président je crois que je viens
voir jeton comparer les stéréotypes
actuelles et les septits de musique
classique c'est pas tout à fait pareil
quand même parce que c'est une telle
sont largement moins subventionnés par
les collectivités publiques voilà la
différence avec la musique du patrimoine
est création vous avez affaire à des
formations et des masses salariales
extrêmement importantes puisque il
s'agit d'orchestre permanent donc c'est
un choix la permanence artistique coûte
extrêmement cher et donc on est dans un
modèle très particulier
de prendre en compte qu'il n'est pas
celui des musiques actuelles donc ça
mérite peut-être une réflexion président
et je pense que notre commission pourra
avoir une vision à cela j'aurais intérêt
à prendre connaissance des missions
orchestre et de la l'étude qui a été
faite à la demande d'ailleurs de chevaux
sur l'art lyrique la mission orlyrick
c'est deux missions qui sont
constituentives à l'heure actuelle d'un
immense travail qui est en cours pour
aller vers un nouveau pacte symphonique
sera cosini par les professionnels et
collectivités territoriales ministères
je pense que ce serait utile pour
éclairer l'ensemble du paysage et les
bonnes décisions à prendre ensemble on
dit dans le rapport je retiens modifier
en ce sens après étude approfondie et
concertation avec l'ensemble des acteurs
il y a donc bien une proposition mais
qui est soumise à concertation parce que
je vois bien je sais bien que voilà il y
a même si même si le rapport se prononce
il propose que tu ce que tu ce que tu
dis c'est à dire de de faire un tour de
temps
bien merci en tout cas pour votre
présentation de ce matin et puis surtout
la qualité de votre rapport qui est
encore une fois très complet qu'il ne
faut pas réduire à la taxe streaming
néanmoins je vais revenir à la taxe
streaming parce que j'ai le souvenir que
l'année dernière à peu près la même
époque quand certains l'ont sorti ça
avait été accompagnés de noms d'oiseaux
etc aller très haut et très vite dans
les tours et c'est déjà un premier
succès pour vous c'est que on n'a pas
entendu les mêmes
oiseaux à l'issue de votre rapport donc
voilà
bon en tout cas merci beaucoup